Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
...the ones who determine
their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal.
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want you all
to think who's next?
Narrator: This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight,
billionaire founder
of a category‐defining
company Spanx,
Sara Blakely, joins the Tank.
I think this is great.
I love it.
This is kind of your
"Oprah" moment.
You get a foam roller!
Everybody gets a foam roller!
So, we're currently
pre‐revenue.
‐Ooh!
‐Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
‐Aah!
‐[ Grunts ]
We retail at $128.
Ouch! Ouch!
‐Oh, man, you're dead.
‐I haven't seen a dime.
You're in a bad deal.
You want a license
to platform?
‐Of course!
‐That's not gonna work.
It could also put you
out of business.
Complete waste of your time.
‐I‐I...
‐I disagree.
Ooh!
‐There's nothing here.
‐Ooh!
I think you're gonna get crushed
like the cockroach you are,
but don't let that
bother you.
I told her ‐‐ I told her
she's gonna be great.
It's like when I came on
the first time,
I just destroyed Kevin.
Ohh!
‐He's never been the same.
‐You're dreaming!
‐[ Laughs ]
Let's do this!
Whoo!
Narrator: First into the tank
is a high‐tech way
to make an important
traditional activity
with your kids more engaging.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Matt Hammersley.
I'm Melissa Hammersley, and
we're from Seattle, Washington.
We're here seeking
$500,000 in exchange
for 10% of our company
Novel Effect,
where we bring
stories to life.
At Novel Effect, we've combined
the tradition of story time
with today's technology
to create magical experiences
with children's books.
And we make that magic
in our app that uses
voice recognition
to perfectly sync theme music,
sound effects,
and even characters' voices
all triggered by you
reading a book out loud.
Just pick a book off
of your shelf at home,
tap the same title
in the Novel Effect app,
then simply read aloud.
Hey, kids, you guys ready
to hear a story?
Yeah!
Oh, awesome!
[ Laughter ]
[ Tone plays ]
App: Up next is Novel Effect,
a company making
story time magic.
This one's called "Novel Effect
Goes to Shark Tank."
[ Music plays ]
Whoa!
There once lived a pair
of brave, inventive swordfish...
Aw!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐...with a simple idea...
[ Ding! ]
Whoa, cool!
...and a very big wish.
[ Chime! ]
So they visit successful,
smart Sharks with a show.
They swim down that big hall
as the doors open wide...
[ "Shark Tank"
theme music plays ]
...then they pitch
their grand plan
with their heads
held quite high.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Whoa!
[ Shimmer! ]
[ Pop! Pop! ]
Wow!
Mr. Wonderful makes
the first offer they need.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐I have an offer for you.
They'll have to act fast,
or hear...
You're dead to me.
[ Chuckles ]
Mark and Lori make offers,
deals sweet as honey.
‐I'm in on that deal, Mark.
‐[ Chuckles ]
Then Kevin breaks in...
I know how to make money.
[ Slot machine chiming ]
The swordfish look at each other
and smile with zeal.
‐Yes!
‐We did it!
Then say it together ‐‐
Sharks, you've got
yourselves a deal!
[ Triumphant music plays ]
[ Laughs ]
Well, kids, thank you so much
for story time.
It's off to bed.
[ Chuckles ]
Yay!
‐All right! That's cool.
‐Bye, kids. Thank you.
We need your help
to scale our business.
Who's ready to make
story time magic with us?
What are your backgrounds?
I'm a graphic designer.
I'm actually a patent attorney
by trade.
That's super‐convenient for you,
isn't it?
‐[ Laughs ] I tell you.
‐Very convenient for us.
As you can imagine,
all of this is patent‐protected.
How did you come up
with this idea.
So, we had this idea
at a baby shower
that was being thrown for us
before our daughter was born.
A friend
was reading to us.
She had the whole room
captivated
with her sound effects and her
little characters' voices.
And it was a light‐bulb
moment.
And Matt literally
couldn't stop thinking about it.
Three months later,
our daughter was born.
We had sold our house
to bootstrap it,
and we had moved the
rest of the way
across the country
to Seattle, Washington.
Wow.
Really?
You sold everything
to bootstrap this company,
moved across the country ‐‐
Why Seattle?
It ‐‐ It ‐‐ Well, Seattle ‐‐
One, we were close to Amazon,
who we thought would be a great
potential corporate partner.
And have you had any other
investors in it to date?
'Cause you put a value on it
of $5 million.
‐Whoa!
‐Absolutely.
So, you know,
I just want to point that out
'cause I love stories, too, and
I can't wait to hear that story.
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah, so, we've raised
$620,000 so far.
Ooh.
Wow.
$500,000 of which was
a convertible note
at a $4 million cap.
And then we just
got an investment
from the Alexa Fund
at Amazon.
What was your pitch to them
in using Alexa?
Well, we can use
any voice service
that we want to run
our storytelling program.
So I think you can imagine
the capabilities of saying
things like, "Alexa,
I want to read
'Where the Wild Things Are'
with Novel Effect."
So, guys, I'm ‐‐
I think this is great.
Thank you.
I have children,
and to think about
making story time
even more engaging
and exciting is awesome.
As a mother, can you tell me
how easy it is
to use and walk me
through what I do?
So, it's very simple.
We have an app that you download
on the App Store.
From there,
we have our selection of books
that we've created,
soundscapes for
that are available for you.
You ‐‐
Can you tell me how many books
are in your selection?
Right now we've got about
75 in our library.
‐Wow.
We are in the process
of building up
our library and working
with our publishing partners.
And what do you have
to pay to license?
We don't actually have to pay
a license fee
for this type
of technology.
And how are you finding
that you are making money
off of the app thus far?
So, we're currently
pre‐revenue
while we build
our library of content.
Our business model
is definitely
a subscription‐based
business model. $5 a month.
Cuban: But how are you gonna
acquire customers?
We're gonna be in
all the bookstores.
We're gonna be
in Barnes & Noble.
We're gonna be on Amazon.
‐Are you sure that's gonna help?
Of course!
That's ‐‐
I mean, if we're at the point
of purchase of the book ‐‐
If you get a book and you see
a sticker on it that says,
"There's a voice‐interactive
soundtrack for this" ‐‐
You couldn't name two products
that have had stickers on them
with web URLs
that you can remember.
You're ‐‐ You're assuming
an enormous conversion ratio
based off of seeing, right,
in a bookstore,
which is declining
in the first place. And ‐‐
Which is why we've partnered
with Amazon, as well. And ‐‐
But then I don't
get to see it, right? So ‐‐
I‐I‐I think that's a valid
partnership.
No, no, no, we're ‐‐ we're ‐‐
we're working with Amazon.
We're hoping to have the link
on Amazon's website, as well,
where you go
to buy this book.
What I'm saying is to
get where you want to go,
given the investment
you have to make for content
on your end, you're making
an enormous binary bet.
So, let me make one thing
very clear.
Our goal and our mission
is not to be the sole
content creators
of this type of
voice‐interactive
entertainment, okay?
You want to license
the platform?
Okay, that's not gonna work.
‐Is that the idea?
‐That's not gonna work.
Absolutely open to license.
That's not gonna work.
Narrator: All Sharks
are still in,
but Mark is skeptical
about the business model
for Novel Effect,
an app that adds
voice‐activated music
and sound effects
while you read a book.
So, let me make
one thing very clear.
Our goal and our mission
is not to be the sole
content creators
of this type of
voice‐interactive
entertainment, okay?
You want to license
the platform?
Cuban:
That's not gonna work.
‐Is that the idea?
‐That's not gonna work.
‐Absolutely open to licensing.
I'm ‐‐ I'm confused at what
you're saying is not gonna work.
Just because you have
great content
doesn't mean people
are going to buy it.
And so what you're bet is ‐‐
and you're betting
the entire company ‐‐
is that if they see
a sticker on
the "Mark Cuban Shark Tank"
book,
they're gonna be so curious
about Novel Effect
that they're gonna
download the app
and they're gonna test it.
I‐I ‐‐
Have you ever used
virtual‐reality goggles?
Yes.
The first response is,
"Wow," right,
"this is pretty cool."
Then you never try it again.
Guys, I think you're
underestimating the challenge,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
‐Thank you, Mark. Appreciate it.
‐Thank you.
John:
Here's where I am with it.
You're asking for
a $5 million valuation.
You know,
for that amount of money,
I can get Earth, Wind & Fire
to come perform for my child
every night.
[ Laughter ]
I just don't feel
strongly enough about it,
I have to take a pass on it.
So I'm out.
At the Learning Company,
we tried
the subscription service,
and what we found was
the parent was willing to pay
a one‐time fee
to buy an experience.
In our case, it was audio CDs
with books.
That was the technology
of the time.
Subscription's never working
for Scholastic,
and we partnered
with them forever.
Getting that parent
at the moment they're making
their reading decision
for their children
is a really short window
of about 60, 90 days.
That's your problem.
Our biggest challenge
at the end of the day
was trying to get
the customer‐acquisition value
less than the 36‐month
lifetime value of the customer.
It was hell on Earth.
That was 30 years ago.
Don't you think that the way
people connect is different?
It has not‐‐ It's nothing
to do with technology.
Social media, tech‐‐ It is
different because today ‐‐
A child is born ‐‐
A child is born right now.
But today ‐‐
Here's the difference.
You're wrong.
You want to know
the big difference?
You're 100% wrong.
The big difference
is that today ‐‐
Thank goodness you know me,
or you would stay
ignorant on this topic.
I'm gonna build a wall
between you and me,
and I'm gonna have
Mark pay for it.
[ Laughter ]
The ‐‐ A child
is born right now...
Wait.
...and how are you gonna get to
their mother in 36 months?
‐Silence.
‐[ Chuckles ]
So ‐‐
Let me finish
my thought, please.
Silence. No.
I'm coming in.
I'm out.
Thanks.
I do not agree
with all the naysayers.
I think this is cool
as cool can be.
‐Thank you.
I love it.
‐But...
‐I love it.
There's no buts.
So I'm gonna give you an offer.
‐Can you get that music rolling?
‐I do think the valuation is,
you know, a little ‐‐
not sure about that.
But...
Wait for it.
...I just want to be along
for the ride.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐And the offer is...?
So my offer is $500,000
for 20%
because I don't know
what I'm gonna have to do,
and I don't know how
I'm gonna get my money back.
‐I would like to counter.
‐Okay.
You know,
we've got other investors
that have already come in.
Would you be willing
to take that same terms
that we've given our prior
investors of a $4 million cap?
Lori, would you want
to go in together?
If Sara and I were
to go in together...
‐Okay, I like that.
‐...and I'm just listening...
‐I love that.
‐...because I've asked you
for the ‐‐ You know,
you get two Sharks,
usually that means
more equity.
Are you willing to give away
more equity?
♪♪
What are you gonna do?
Greiner: Wait a minute.
As I think about it,
you know,
I could offer
to go in with Sara,
but the problem with that is,
is you don't really
want to give away
a lot of equity.
You know what I
can do for you.
‐Ooh!
‐Ouch! Ouch!
The next book is gonna be
"Sara Under the Bus."
Can you sweeten
that a little bit
because I'm
a wonderful Shark?
Would you be willing
to do $500,000 for 13%?
♪♪
15%, you're on.
15%?
What do you think?
‐Yeah.
‐Yeah? We'll take that.
‐Yeah!
‐Let's do it.
‐Yeah.
‐Thank you so much. Ohh!
‐I love it! I love it!
I love it! Yay!
‐So exciting!
‐Thank you so much, Lori.
I'm so excited.
And now I have a free
patent attorney?
Yeah, well, you know...
[ Laughter ]
I hope you're happy
with her.
You don't know
what I was gonna offer.
Well, you know ‐‐
That's called her problem.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
Yeah!
Oh, that was awesome!
We did it!
If we had any regrets,
it was not hearing Sara's offer,
but Lori put a great offer
on the table,
and when you have that,
you take it.
‐What about her business?
‐Lori threw Sara under the bus.
The relationship is ruined
between them.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner:
The end. [ Laughs ]
♪♪
I was born in Clearwater Beach,
Florida.
I was always entrepreneurial.
I started sewing charms
onto socks
and selling them
at swim practice.
And then it was roller‐rink
parties for the neighborhood,
where I would charge
people admission.
I've been dreaming up ideas
since I was a little girl.
In college,
I basically failed the LSAT,
which is the entrance exam
to law school.
So life had other plans
for me.
I ended up selling
fax machines
door‐to‐door for seven years,
and it was tough.
I was kicked out of buildings.
I had people rip up
my business card.
I had this moment where I pulled
off the side of the road,
and I thought,
"This is not my life.
I need to reinvent this."
So I wrote in my journal
that night,
"I want to invent a product
that I can sell
to millions of people that will
make them feel good."
Two years later, I was getting
ready to go to a party.
Like so many women,
I could not find
the right undergarment
to wear under my outfit.
So I cut the feet out
of pantyhose,
threw them on under
my white pants,
and it got rid of all the lines
and made a flawless look.
And so that's how Spanx
was born.
I sent Oprah a gift basket
when I first started,
and then Oprah calls
and says that she chose it
as her favorite product
of the year.
That's when it exploded.
Spanx today
is a lifestyle brand.
I turned the industry
on its head
because I recognized
that so few companies
care about how we felt
in our clothes.
When you see a problem
and you can solve it,
those make the best products.
So, you put it on, and then you
get the perfect layering.
I'm a big believer
that the world will be
a better place if women
were elevated on the planet
and women everywhere
were given the chance
to fulfill their dreams.
I'm doing it for the women
that came before me
that didn't have this
opportunity and for the women
around the world that still,
to this day,
don't have this opportunity.
I'm so excited to be a Shark,
to hear the ideas,
to support entrepreneurs
that maybe some of my
life experience can
be passed on to them
at just the right moment
in their journey.
And maybe we end up
becoming partners.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a dad
who believes he has a brand
for an underserved market.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Andrew Bentley.
I'm originally
from Madison, Wisconsin.
I'm the founder
of Father Figure,
a paternity clothing brand
for the modern dad.
I'm seeking $80,000
for 15% equity in my company.
The person that's had the
largest influence on my life
weighed just 4 1/2 pounds
when I met him.
When I first held my tiny,
but thankfully healthy, son,
I fell in love.
I was hooked on being
a dad and a caretaker.
But in the transition to parent,
very few things from books
to clothing to gear spoke
my language as a dad.
And I'm not the only one
that feels this way.
The amount of time that dads
today spend with their kids
has tripled from 50 years ago.
I'm building a brand
for these modern dads.
Father Figure's clothes
and accessories combine
fashion and function
to make both dad and baby
look good
while they feel good.
Now, to showcase
my clothing line,
I'm gonna treat you Sharks
to a dad‐and‐baby fashion show.
[ Chuckles ]
First up is Ezekiel
and his son, Nazir.
Aw! [ Laughs ]
Ezekiel's wearing
our paternity shirt.
It's 100% cotton,
has a relaxed neckline,
it has a patch over the shoulder
for snuggling that baby,
and a loop on the hip
for storing
our bandana‐print burp rag.
Next up is Fausto.
He's wearing our Booker
denim shirt,
which is perfect for a day out
on the town with your baby.
[ Laughter ]
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐It has soft patches...
‐So cute!
‐...in places where dads hold
their babies the most
and a loop on the hip
for storing burp rags
or even toys.
Now, I've taken Father Figure
from crawling to walking,
and I'm looking for a partner
to get us to running.
Thank you so much.
It's an absolute joy to be here.
I'd love to take
any questions you have.
My first question ‐‐
Are these stunt babies?
[ Laughs ]
These are ‐‐
Because they don't cry.
They're so cute!
They're so special.
My kids
were never like that.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Aw, look at her.
‐Daymond, that's for you.
‐I'll take that one.
‐Thank you so much.
For Lori.
‐This is for Lori.
‐For Lori?
‐Thank you, Daymond.
‐Hi Sara.
‐Hi!
‐This is for you.
‐Thank you.
‐And, Mark.
‐Thank you, sir.
‐Thank you so much.
Thanks.
It's ‐‐
really feels beautiful.
Thank you.
Okay, so,
it's gonna be nap time soon,
so we're gonna have to say
goodbye to the dads and babies.
Oh.
Ohh!
Good job, guys.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
You guys did amazing.
‐Bye.
‐Bye!
‐Not even a peep.
So, the line is bandanas
and t‐shirts?
Correct.
Right now we have shirts,
accessories like bandanas,
and I'm working on a swaddle,
as well.
Are you the designer
of these clothing?
I'm not a clothing designer,
but I did design these.
When my wife went back to work,
our son was 12 weeks old.
It was my first time taking care
of a baby, right?
So I was super‐nervous.
He was colicky.
And I'm bouncing him
on an exercise ball
like six, seven hours a day.
And when he'd spit up,
it was a critical moment.
I needed a burp rag, and I could
never find it, and...
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, the memories.
‐Yeah!
‐[ Laughs ]
And I'd always told my wife,
"I want paternity clothes."
And I would get laughed at.
So I bought a button fastener,
and I fastened a burp rag
on my shirt so I would
never lose it.
And my son also has
sensitive skin,
so when I would sooth him,
it would be rough on his skin.
So I started putting patches
on my shirts
in places where I
would hold him.
So, when did you start this?
What year?
And how many have you sold?
So, this is the 11th month,
and I've done $33,000 in sales.
‐That's not bad at all.
‐Where are you making the sales?
I started a Kickstarter campaign
that ended last July.
I raised $30,000 in 30 days.
Okay, so wait, so wait, so wait.
Your total sales are $33,000.
Correct.
And you raised $30,000
at Kickstarter.
‐Right.
‐And how are you manufacturing?
So that means
you've only sold $2,500
worth of product
in 11 months.
Is the market
telling you something?
No, so the customer validation
is there.
I mean, with Kickstarter,
the last three days,
we did $12,000.
‐Okay.
Tell us about post‐Kickstarter,
where you're selling and how.
So after Kickstarter closed,
I was still working
a full‐time job.
‐Doing what?
‐I was at Google.
‐Uh‐huh.
‐I worked on the digital divide.
So about 30%
of American families
don't have Internet in the home,
and it's mostly underserved,
lower‐income,
black and Latino families.
I worked with the federal
government and nonprofits
to address a lot
of those barriers.
Are you still at Google,
or you've left?
I left Google.
Are you doing this
full time?
I am now, yeah.
Andrew, I have four children
under the age of 7,
and I have a really hands‐on
partner ‐‐ my husband, Jesse.
And at Spanx, you know,
we give paternity leave
as well as maternity leave.
So I really love this idea
of paternity wear.
I love the branding,
and I love the angle.
What are you making
the garments at?
Let's say that denim shirt.
What are you making
the denim shirt at,
and what is it
retailing for?
Landed ‐‐ $76,
and I'm retailing at $128.
You sell the denim shirt
for $128?
That's correct.
So, you know, I liked and was
intrigued by when you had
little things that held,
like, a teething ring, a toy.
You know, it's almost like
a tool belt, right...
‐Right, right.
‐...for your baby's stuff?
Yeah, absolutely.
So I'm thinking
that's the way
that you really need to go
versus a clothing line.
I can give you my advice,
but I can't give you an offer.
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Cuban: Look, Andrew,
you're doing all the blocking
and tackling
exactly right.
You start with Kickstarter,
you know,
get a feel from your customers,
but the problem is nobody said,
"I need one. I need
to get this for my friend.
I can't believe
they lived without it."
That's the bridge
you have to cross right now.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
O'Leary: Andrew, let me take
a shot at it.
Unlike the other Sharks,
I don't want to give you
any encouragement.
There's nothing here.
I disagree.
Look, someone has
to tell you the truth.
I'm doing it for you.
It's a complete waste
of your time.
This is going to zero.
I'm out.
♪♪
Daymond, with FUBU, I mean,
you built FUBU in Queens.
I grew up in a working‐class
community, right?
I didn't have a lot of money.
I know we have similar
backgrounds,
and this is a space
that you excel.
You're one of my idols.
I think it's a little too early,
and my biggest challenge is
if you're the tech guy
and you can't get it out,
I'm the fashion guy.
I would lean on everything
for a person
that worked at Google
to get it out.
You haven't gotten it
to that level.
It's too early for me.
I'm out.
One thing I want to say is that
I understand this is early.
I didn't come in here with
millions of dollars of sales.
I hear you guys say it
all the time ‐‐
"The rug is for ‐‐
It's for people trying to do
new, innovative things."
I'm early.
I'm here.
I'm ‐‐ I have a plan.
Things are starting to work.
I need a little boost.
And I think
you can provide that.
Blakely: Andrew,
you're just starting out.
You have a great story.
Where I'm struggling
is on the product.
Maternity wear
is really functional.
I mean, it serves a very
specific need for the woman
as she ‐‐
her body's changing.
This ‐‐ I'm struggling with it
and I'm trying to think
of what else I would add
and I'm coming up dry.
So for that reason, and I wish
you the best, I'm out.
But I would encourage you
to just keep thinking
about your products.
‐Sure.
O'Leary: All right,
we're done here.
‐Listen, you're so ‐‐
‐We're done here. We're done.
You're so close.
We're done, we're done,
we're done.
You're one really good product
idea away.
‐Andrew, thank you.
‐Thank you so much.
It was really a pleasure.
‐Thank you.
Thanks, Andrew.
Good luck, buddy.
‐Good luck.
‐I wish you all the best.
Good luck.
I didn't get a deal,
but at the same time,
I'm gonna keep moving forward
and learn from it.
‐The product was off.
‐Right.
And product is everything.
But why not encourage him?
You know what's
everything? Why?
Think of all the great things
that have happened in life
because people were encouraged.
Because I want him to do
something else where
he actually be successful.
You're gonna get him to spend
another 24 months ‐‐
‐Get him, Sara! Get him!
‐24 months to do...
Listen! You're not ‐‐
...of his time wasting it.
That's ridiculous.
‐Talk to her hand.
‐[ Laughs ]
That's what I'm gonna do.
Talk to Sara's hand.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Next!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the tank is
a solution to a hairy problem.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Jennifer.
My name's Gifford.
And we're from Salem, Utah.
We're the inventors
of the DrainWig,
and we're here seeking
a $300,000 investment
in exchange for 5% equity
in our company.
Wow.
Whoa!
Boy!
‐Whew!
‐Sharks, we have a problem.
We actually
have five problems.
We have five daughters.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Hmm.
♪♪
Oh, man, you're dead.
Wow!
[ Laughter ]
We love our daughters.
That is not the problem.
It is their hair!
[ Laughs ]
They are professional drain
cloggers.
[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, Lord.
‐These five girls
all sharing one shower
equal the wet hair‐ball
nightmare.
Sharks, let's be real.
Cleaning the shower drain
can be a major source
of contention in the home
because it is a dirty,
disgusting job
that nobody wants to do!
[ Laughter ]
Simply guide your DrainWig
down the drain.
It prevents the clogs
that would normally
get stuck in the pipe.
After two to four months,
it removes right through
the drain cover
without you ever
having to touch
the nasty hair.
Jennifer: It has a
stainless‐steel chain
with colorful rubber whiskers
that trap the hair.
We have two
retail designs.
The DrainWig for the shower
has a cute flower cap,
and the DrainWig
for the bathtub
anchors to the side
of the tub with a suction cup,
which allows you to use
your stopper as usual.
Thank you, Sharks.
Our daughters
will now give each of you
samples of the DrainWig.
So, what did you do
in a previous life
that you got five daughters?
I don't know. It was destiny,
I gue‐‐ For sure, destiny.
Hi! Thank you!
‐This one's for Lori.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Ah, thank you!
‐They're both for me.
Good job up there.
Greiner: How did you come up
with this idea?
Jennifer: So, what happened
was this invention
was a complete accident,
okay?
So, we're weirdos.
We floss and brush our teeth
in the shower.
[ Chuckles ]
And one day, I look down
in the drain
and there was something brown
and it was moving
and I was like, "Gifford,
there's a gopher in the drain!"
And I kid you not.
He pulled this cover off
and on the end of it
was this long piece
of dental floss
and on the end of it
was this massive wad of hair.
We were solving our problem,
and we were like,
"Hey, wait a second.
We ‐‐ We could make a product
aft‐‐ out of this."
What are you making it for,
and what are you selling it for?
It's ‐‐ It's being made for
about $1.20 for the double pack.
What does the double pack
go for?
‐Double pack goes for $9.99.
‐$9.99.
Margins are excellent.
John: Where is this available
right now?
‐Well, it's available ‐‐
‐All the big‐box stores.
‐Walmart.
‐Bed, Bath.
‐It's everywhere?
‐So you're well‐distributed.
‐Yes.
‐We are.
O'Leary:
Just give me the numbers.
Okay, we've sold $14.2 million
in retail.
‐Wow!
‐Whoa!
That's a lot.
Greiner: Was this
an infomercial?
‐Yes.
If you're everywhere
and you're really
doing great,
why are you here?
Why are you here?
Ha, ha, ha.
We thought you'd never ask.
We are so glad
you asked that question.
We went to trade shows.
Okay, we ‐‐ we didn't know
anything about this industry,
and so one day,
I came home from a trade show.
A couple days later,
I got a phone call
from an
infomercial company.
‐Did you do a deal with them?
‐We did a deal with them.
We started selling.
They said,
"We're gonna pass you on
to the largest infomercial
company in America."
We've been in our agreement
for three years.
We've been issued $800,000
in royalty payments.
‐That ‐‐ In aggregate?
‐In three years.
So is it a licensed deal
that you had
for three years
with this company?
‐Yes.
‐It is. We're in our third year.
‐And does that run out?
‐We gave them five years.
We've been splitting it,
and our deal with them
ends in March.
But if we renegotiate,
it would end immediately.
What I want to know is does
anybody else have equity?
We own everything.
We had an angel round
investor.
We paid them back
with the royalty.
We paid them back $300,000.
And ‐‐ And ‐‐
And so they're out.
They're out.
You told me that you've done
$14.2 million
in sales as a product.
It was done by an
infomercial company for you.
Yes.
Of that,
during the same period,
you collected $800,000,
which is around 5.4%.
‐Right.
‐The reason you're here
on the carpet at "Shark Tank"
is you want to get
the lion's share of this now.
‐Absolutely.
‐Yes.
‐And you need a partner.
You're in a bad deal.
That's really what
this comes down to.
Thank you. You know what it
feels like to walk into Walmart?
I walk into Walmart, and I see
[voice breaking] my product,
and I haven't seen a dime.
We have ‐‐ take all that money
'cause we take half of it
and pay it to
the first infomercial that ‐‐
that brought us, and we ‐‐
so we give half of it to them.
Our goal is to take
this product, form a company,
and take it to the market
and start making
the money ourselves.
So you want ‐‐
you want my $300,000
to actually create a company
with ‐‐ hire people...
‐Yeah.
‐...get warehouse space...
Get warehouse,
manufacturing logistics.
...getting logistics.
The motivation is clear now.
You want to take control
of your product. Right?
‐Yes. Mm‐hmm.
‐Yes.
That's why you're here.
How are you going
to execute on that?
That's what I'm not sure about.
‐Right.
So, we need your help
and resources.
That's a problem.
Look, I don't want
to make an investment
and then have to reinvent
your business for you.
I'm out.
O'Leary: I look at this
and say to myself,
"Okay, I give you $300,000
and start the journey with you.
5% doesn't even get me up
in the morning."
Not worth it.
So I got to get some skin
in the game here.
I do ‐‐ I would do this deal
for 20%.
For me, that makes sense.
And I'd be willing
to do that right now
and go through all
of the headaches
that we're gonna have
'cause I'm not sure
these guys are gonna
roll over and say,
"Take the product away from us.
I was gonna make
$4 million on it.
I'm okay with that."
You're gonna need
a really nasty friend,
and I happen
to be that person.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐That's why we're here.
Yeah.
Listen, as ‐‐
as an entrepreneur, like,
when I first started, I had a
really big company call me.
They took me to dinner.
They acted like
they wanted to buy me.
And then a month later,
they launched an $8 million
ad campaign with a girl
who looked exactly like me
wearing a knock‐off product
of Spanx.
So all the sweat equity
you guys are putting into it,
I can't imagine how I would feel
if I knew that most of all
that sweat equity was having
to go to somebody else.
I own 100% of my company.
I think you can keep doing it
on your own.
And for that reason,
I'm ‐‐ I'm out.
Okay.
5%'s not gonna get me up
in the morning,
but I like the product.
$300,000 for 20%.
‐That sounds familiar.
‐That sounds good.
And that's exactly
what his offer was.
Jennifer: Right.
I'm going to give you an offer
for $300,000, but for 25%.
Ooh!
Lori! Ouch.
Keeps on getting worse,
not better, doesn't it?
‐I‐I ‐‐ It's ‐‐ It's higher.
‐That's much worse.
It's higher because retail
and infomercial
is my sweet spot.
It's an enormous job.
Would anybody be interested
in doing a deal
at $300,000
for 10%?
‐At 10%?
You're treating it like it's a‐a
new product to the market.
Wait, I don't think you ‐‐
I don't think
you heard what he said.
We gave you the offers.
♪♪
15% for $300,000.
You know, the biggest complaint
in hotels
is clogged drains.
You know, I'll be very honest.
I actually like that.
That is a great concept.
‐You know what, yes.
I'll do it.
‐You'll do it?
‐You have a deal.
‐You've got a deal.
I'm sorry.
I didn't even ask you.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thank you.
I'm really intrigued.
I've got to tell you so.
‐Thank you. You're the most ‐‐
‐Thank you.
Congratulations, guys.
Good luck.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Good luck.
‐Bye.
You swooped in like a buzzard
on a gut wagon.
‐Yes, I did.
‐You're disgusting.
I like this deal.
Gifford.
That was insane.
That was crazy.
That was intense.
[ Cheering ]
‐Wow!
‐Did you hear?!
Did you hear it?
‐Yeah.
Jennifer:
When I go into that Walmart now,
now I can walk in and say,
"That's ours.
We got it here.
And we worked our little
tails off to get here."
And we'll be able to see
the fruits of our labor.
Yeah!
[ All cheer ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is a better version
of a ubiquitous
workout necessity.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks, I'm Nate Lawrie,
and I'm from Santa Barbara,
California.
My company is Brazyn Life,
and I'm seeking $225,000
in exchange for 10%
of my company.
When I played in the NFL,
I took a lot of hits.
[ Grunting ]
Not today, Tom!
[ Laughter ]
Hi. I'm Tom Hopkins,
Nate's business partner.
Just trying to keep him
on his toes.
As a professional football
player,
taking hits
was an everyday occurrence.
I love football,
but my back ‐‐ not so much.
Foam rolling was a life saver
for my career.
It helped me keep my focus
on playing and not being stuck
in the training room
waiting for treatment.
But, look, they're bulky, and
they're a pain to travel with.
That's why I set out
to create something better.
I want to make the world's
most portable foam roller
that doesn't suck.
‐This is the Morp.
‐[ Laughs ]
It is the world's first
collapsible foam roller.
In an instant, you can pull it
out of a backpack,
a carry‐on, or a small gym bag,
pop it open...
and be giving your body
some much‐needed TLC.
The patented surface texture
is perfect at releasing knots
and flushing toxins
from the muscles.
When you're done,
you collapse back down,
and you're on the go.
So, Sharks, which of you wants
to roll with us?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Right.
Would any‐‐ anyone like to get
up and give it a try?
Cool!
Nate, it's intriguing because,
you know, I do roll.
I want to try.
There is a market for this,
no question about it.
In our locker room, we must have
350 different rollers.
And I bet your trainers
and your coaching staff
are packing big boxes
when they go to away games.
How does that feel, Mark?
It feels like, you know,
a foam roller with spikes
or whatever
they're called.
Yeah, what those nubs are
is they do a really good job
at helping you pinpoint
knots in the muscles
and really help you
to release those.
That's nice.
So, to collapse it,
what you want to do
is you want to locate
these two "push" symbols
on either side and push firmly
all the way down.
‐Look at this. That's cool.
‐Yep.
You can put it back in your
backpack or your carry‐on.
‐So, see you guys all kind of...
‐That's pretty cool!
That's cool the way
it just pops open.
‐Thank you.
‐We spent a lot of time
developing the product
and making it
extremely user‐friendly.
‐Pass it down.
‐Thank you.
‐Mr. Wonderful.
So what Tom is handing you out
now is your own Morp.
The skins are removable,
washable sleeves.
There you go.
‐Appreciate it.
‐It collapses back down.
‐That's pretty clever.
Nate, what team
did you play for?
So, I started off in Tampa,
and I played for the Saints
and the Buccaneers
then the Bengals.
‐Go Bucs!
‐And I played ‐‐ Go Buccaneers.
Did you design this?
That's my design, yes.
‐And you injured yourself?
‐I did.
So, in my third year in the NFL,
I was with the Saints,
and unfortunately, I had this
nagging back injury
that just kept getting worse
and worse throughout the season.
I kept fighting through it
because I didn't want
to let pain get in the way
of my dreams,
but it wasn't sustainable.
And as the team went on to the
NFC Championship game that year,
I was actually laying at home
recovering from a spine surgery.
So as I got into the recovery
process, I became devoted.
I used the foam roller,
and I don't think
I would have played
another five years
of professional football.
‐Really?
‐I wanted to find something
that I could easily
travel with.
And so I went to a local
hardware store,
built a very rudimentary
prototype in the garage.
When it didn't collapse under
my massive 260 pounds
of tight‐end weight,
I knew I had the opportunity
to make something
that was really cool.
[ Chuckles ]
So ‐‐ So, to be clear,
you think that the use
of a foam roller helped you stay
in the NFL for five more years?
‐Absolutely.
‐Wow.
Is there anything else
close to this on the market?
Is there another collapsible
foam roller?
So, there's nothing out there
on the market currently.
‐Do you have a patent?
‐It is patent‐pending.
So, we're also patent‐pending
in Europe,
in Canada, and Australia.
Has anybody
knocked it off yet?
‐No.
How much
do you sell them for?
What do they cost?
How many have you sold?
The whole routine.
So, we retail these
for $68.
So, they cost right now, for our
first production run, $26.75.
‐Ooh. That's expensive.
‐$26.75 landed?
Yeah.
How much is a typical
foam roller?
A typical foam roller
is gonna run you
around $40.
‐Wait a second.
There's lots of cheaper
foam rollers than 40 bucks.
foam rollers...
The cheap ‐‐ Yeah, the cheap
ones that ‐‐
...but you're buying those ‐‐
Yeah, they break down.
Yeah, they break down. You're
buying them a couple of times.
Yeah, but those
are 15, 20 bucks, right?
Yeah, they're $15, $14.95.
People don't know the
difference, right?
We've already identified ways
that we're gonna be able
to get that down to around $20
by the end of the year.
Okay, well, there you go.
And this month we're gonna do
$50,000 in sales.
We're projecting $2.4 million
over the next 12 months...
‐Whoa!
‐...with a 20% net profit.
So we're profitable
this month.
What is it specifically
that you need?
Right, so your name value is ‐‐
would be great.
You own a‐a professional
sporting‐goods team.
‐I own a team, too.
‐A sporting‐goods team?
‐Yeah.
‐[ Laughing ] Yeah!
‐Sorry. So it's ‐‐
‐I own part of an NBA team.
I own the ‐‐
‐Sara, what team?
‐The Hawks.
‐You go, girl.
[ Laughs ]
So, are you making them
overseas,
or are you making them here?
We make them at our
manufacturing
facility
in Romania.
‐Oh.
‐Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
You own the manufacturing
facility in Romania?
Yes, so,
my wife's father‐in‐law
owns a precision parts
manufacturing company.
He had a lot of extra square
footage in his factory.
You trust them.
You have a relationship.
Nate, your wife's father‐in‐law
is your dad.
[ Chuckles ]
‐Yeah.
‐Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe I misspoke.
My wife's ‐‐
'Cause he's own‐‐ he's owning
the sporting‐goods team,
and it's getting confusing.
‐[ Laughs ]
I'm just gonna tie my tongue
and just walk away now.
No, I'm sorry.
Yeah. You're right.
My ‐‐ My wife's father.
Do you ‐‐ Do you have
flexibility in this 10%?
'Cause I don't think you're
worth $2.25 million right now.
I think that
the valuation is fair.
We do project $2.4 million
over the next 12 months.
We're not even
on Amazon yet.
Amazon is by far
the biggest distributor
of foam rollers out there.
John: Let me get the ball
rolling.
Let me tell you something.
‐[ Chuckles ]
I love this, so I'm just gonna
really offer money.
What's your offer?
$225,000 for 15%.
Ooh!
Okay, I'll do the deal
for $225,000 for 20%
because one video of me
in my underwear
rolling is gonna blow this thing
right out of the water.
[ Laughter ]
It could also put you
out of business.
So...?
‐Anybody else?
‐Mark, what are you doing?
‐I'm listening.
‐Of course.
‐You're listening.
‐We're listening, too.
‐We're very curious.
Carry on.
Let's hear your offers,
ladies.
I am gonna say you guys
have a lot of challenge
ahead of you because this is
a demonstration product.
I mean, I didn't have
any money to advertise.
My moment was being on "Oprah."
So this is kind
of your "Oprah" moment.
You get a foam roller!
You get ‐‐
Everybody gets a foam roller!
But, here, listen, your price
is a little concerning.
Your margin's
really concerning.
But the product is so unique.
So I'm very interested.
But I want to hear
what Mark has to say.
And your offer is...?
As do I.
[ Chuckles ]
‐Mark's out.
‐Mark's out?
‐There you have it.
‐Whoa.
‐Mark!
‐Thank you, Mark.
Can we ask you
why you're out?
Doesn't matter.
Um, I am very well‐versed
in the infomercial world.
We just did
our Simply Fit Board.
I happen to like
that Sara has a team.
Between the two of us,
we could probably bring
a lot to the table
in different ways.
I know what I can do,
and that is blow up product
in a demonstrable way,
and Sara could help
in the arena of sports.
So we could
team up together...
‐Yes.
‐...and offer you
$225,000 at 20%.
‐Ooh!
‐But you're getting two sharks.
‐Aah!
‐So it's 10% and 10%.
I would definitely do
Mr. Wonderful's deal over that.
Now, we are more
than they are.
You just need one
Mr. Wonderful.
But we need to know
if Sara is interested.
Sara, you want to come in
on this?
Yes.
Okay, guys, you have three
offers on the table.
‐It's not a problem.
‐Your other two offers ‐‐
So ‐‐ So do you want two Sharks
for $225,000,
20% of your business,
or do you want...?
Would you guys be willing
to match Daymond's offer?
$225,000 for 15%.
‐Why would we match his offer...
‐It makes it ‐‐
...when you're
getting two of us...
Yeah.
‐...versus one?
‐It makes it harder for us ‐‐
If you think two Sharks
are important, watch this.
‐The answer ‐‐ The answer's no.
‐Shazam!
I'm in with Daymond. Two Sharks.
‐The answer's no, and we want ‐‐
‐Just like that.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐All right?
‐Okay.
‐All right.
‐Oh, a horrifying thought ‐‐
him in his underwear
on a roller.
‐So, but we stay on 20%.
‐I agree.
‐20%.
And, by the way, guys, I am
pretty integrated in CrossFit.
But if it's two Sharks
you want, you got it.
You've got Mr. Wonderful
with Daymond,
or you have the Sharkettes.
You've got to make
a decision, guys.
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Nate and Tom have two offers
on the table
for their collapsible
foam‐roller company Brazyn.
Lori and Sara have offered
$225,000 for a 20% stake.
And Kevin and Daymond have
offered $225,000 for 20%.
I'm gonna make one more
counter‐proposal.
Would you do $250,000
for the 20%?
So, $25,000 more?
Why are you asking that?
Because ‐‐
For a lot of reasons.
The cash is gonna help
our business,
and it's gonna help us
to grow the business.
Um, And it also ‐‐
Kevin, you want to do that?
And we came in with the
valuation...
You want it?
...that's already been ‐‐
So you want to bring that
to me and Sara.
Done. We'll do that deal.
We'll take that deal, okay?
‐No, we'll do the deal!
‐You'll do the deal?
‐We'll do the deal.
‐We'll take that!
We'll take that!
Hold on. We'll take that!
‐Hold on.
‐Not so fast, big guy.
Wait a minute.
Let's clarify.
‐We are matching the offer.
Who are you offering that to ‐‐
them or us?
‐We matched the offer.
‐We just matched that offer.
Can we step back
for a second?
‐Just a moment?
‐Guys...
You guys, we have ‐‐ we have two
outstanding offers on the table.
Go ahead. Step back.
I think...
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
♪♪
All right.
We're going
with the Sharkettes!
‐Whoo!
‐Hold on.
‐Ohh!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Whoo!
‐Boom‐shaka‐laka!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Yay!
‐That's awesome!
‐Genius.
‐Yay!
‐Oh, it's gonna be so exciting.
Kevin, fortunately you're
gonna be in your underwear
'cause you just got spanked.
[ Laughs ]
‐Yay! Yay!
‐Yes!
‐Yay!
‐[ Laughs ]
Congratulations, guys.
‐So smart.
They have a patent pending
on it.
It fits the criteria of filling
the white space...
[ High pitched voice ]
It fits the criteria.
...which is something that
hasn't ‐‐ Oh, my gosh!
Whoo!
[ Both laugh ]
What just happened.
Lawrie: Those are two powerful
businesswomen
who we respect a ton.
Having both of them onboard
is a dream come true.